welcome back to another Ocho TV episode
of tech and fails of the week
the content shown in this video has been
submitted by various players to ochodo
TV Clips are compiled weekly for a
series of videos highlighting specific
players of their gameplay for the Tekken
Community by no means was it reused or
stolen without permission to the
rightful owner
[Music]
oh
what's up
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
yeah Spanish
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't think
foreign
[Music]
dude
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
[Music]
foreign